[موسيقى]
ضع ابهامك في اتجاه جبهتك مع سحبه بعيدا
قليلا او لوح بيدك هكذا يؤدي الكثيرون
التحيه بين بعضهم لكن قله يلاحظون انهم
بذلك يستخدمون لغه الاشاره التي ترتبط
بشكل مباشر بالصم والبكم فكيف اصبحت
الايماءات الجسديه لغه للتخاطب
يبدا الرضيع بالاشاره الى الاشياء قبل ان
ينطقها هكذا يمكن القول ان لغه الاشاره
اول طريقه للتعبير عند الانسان اما اعتماد
الاشاره كلغه للتواصل فهو امر اخر قد يعود
لنحو اكثر من 200 عام يذكر التاريخ ان
الامريكيين الاصليين استخدموا ايماءات
اليد للتواصل كما استخدم الرهبان
الفنديكيين الايماءات خلال فترات صمتهم
اليوميه ومن هنا فكر الراهب الاسباني
فيدرو ديليون في استخدام لافتات للتواصل
مع طلابه الصم خلال القرن السادس عشر ثم
قام بتكييف الايماءات لتصبح بمثابه لغه
اشاره رسميه لضعاف السمع
في عام 1620 قام خوان بابلو بونيت وهو رجل
دين اسباني ايضا بتعليم الصم نطق الكلمات
عن طريق بناء جمل ذات مخزن تدريجيا تحت ما
سماه الابجديه التوضيحيه حيث استخدم اليد
اليمنى لتصوير اشكال تعبر عن كل حرف لكنه
واجه مشكلات في وصف كلمات الربط
تزامنا مع ذلك كان سكان جزيره مارسيز
الامريكيه قد ابتكروا لغه اشاره خاصه بهم
حيث كانوا يعانون من انتشار جينات الصمم
في عام
1775 وفيما كان تعليم السم حكرا على
الاغنياء انشا القس الكاثوليكي الفرنسي
تشارلز ميشيل دولبي اول مدرسه عامه
للاطفال الصوم في باريس حيث قام بترجمه
الابجديه الفرنسيه الى قاموس يتضمن
الايماءات والمفاهيم والافكار الرمزيه
بدلا من الاحرف فقط فانتشرت لغته عبر
اوروبا والولايات المتحده واصبح يعرف بابي
الصم في القرن التاسع عشر قام توماس
هوبكنز قالو ديت وهو وزير من ولايه
كانيتكت بزياره اوروبا بغرض مساعده ابنه
جاره الصماء فالتقى هناك مدربه لغه
الاشاره نوران كليرك حيث طور لغه الاشاره
الامريكيه اي اس ال مستعينين بلغه الاشاره
الفرنسيه
واشارات مارسيس ونظام التخاطب بين
الامريكيين الاصليين واسس اول مدرسه
امريكيه لتعليم الصم قبل ان تبدا الشعوب
بابتكار لغات خاصه بها فعلى سبيل المثال
تستخدم الدول العربيه باستثناء دول المغرب
العربي التي تعتمد لغه مطوره عن اللغه
الفرنسيه لغه متشابهه تقريبا لولا اختلاف
اللهجات
اليوم ورغم ان هناك اكثر من 300 لغه اشاره
حول العالم الا ان مستخدمي هذه اللغات حول
العالم يدينون لها بنجاحها في كسر صمتهم
وتحقيق اندماجهم في المجتمعات المحليه